who
credit any specific project you've done
with
kind of i guess hitting that point where
you've gained more clarity yourself as
far as
what trajectory you want your career to
take and what roles really interest you
um well i think for me getting to be
a very small part of once upon a time in
hollywood and working with quentin
tarantino
was like i constantly battle between
you know if you say something out loud
are you jinxing it or are you
manifesting it do you know what i mean
i'm always like okay do i say it or do i
keep it inside like what
like am i gonna is it not gonna happen
because i want it to happen or is it
gonna happen because i want it to happen
like i just
i i fluctuate between that
in my life but a huge dream of mine was
to work with quentin tarantino like i
i've i've wanted that since i saw
kill bill for the first time you know
and i um
and so having that sort of come true was
like a moment of this weird like relief
or so you know what i mean it's just
like oh my god like
like it was it was just one of those
moments that was so exciting and then
being on that set you know i i was there
for
almost like three weeks to to do my part
because
he has that sort of luxury of of time to
really
put into each sort of vignette that
makes up you know his films
and um it was like
it just reminded me of why i love being
an actor
and why this is what i want to do and
that there's like
no better adrenaline rush than like
being on a set with
a director that you admire and like a
cinematographer that you admire an actor
that you admire and just like
every piece of the puzzle is so
extraordinary and so
like larger than life and also very
intimate and like
very much about we're making a movie
and like it's a beautiful day to make a
movie you know and like
quentin his his sort of child-like
love of like just genuine love of
film and television just comes through
in any conversation that i think
anyone could ever have with him and it
just rubs off on
everybody on the set and so it really
was a moment of like
just remembering why this is this is
what i've chosen to do with my life and
that i i do love it
i'm jumping ahead a little here but i
can't not ask about this more
when you did once especially given the
fact that your character
you know she has so much confidence and
exudes so much authority and then you're
working alongside someone you've dreamed
of working with so many other iconic
actors does
does it like click into place for you
immediately or do the nerves still
bubble up in moments like that well you
know it was
again it was very luxurious to be able
to film that sequence
in order you know so the first thing
that i filmed was
literally the shot of me appearing
behind the screen door and like the sun
kind of rising over my face and illumina
and that was
kind of my first thing so that was good
because it's like i didn't have to say
any lines yet you know it was kind of
like more of a physicality thing the
camera was kind of far away i was like
okay
we're easing our way into the like
you know this close-up shot of my
eyebrows okay good we're like
easing me into it a little bit it was
interesting though because i did
feel like the red hair and the brown
contact lenses and the sort of
um freckle makeup and the
the dirt and everything was almost like
a shield like i didn't feel like myself
i
really did feel like another character
and she is such a wild eyed kind of
could do or say anything character that
i i felt
i felt empowered by that um
i was definitely nervous but i but but
again
even though it is a larger-than-life
experience quentin really makes it very
special and very intimate you know he's
like
right there behind the camera and he's
worked with so many of the same people
over and over again which i also think
is something that i've noticed that
a lot of the greats most of the greats
do they keep
their crew very close and they're all
very loyal to one another and i think
that's really
beautiful and seeing that camaraderie up
close was really
incredible and it made for a very safe
environment